Miranda Kerr and snapchat founder Evan  Spiegel have tied the knot  [Music]  the 34 year old model and the 26 year  old billionaire have married after two  years together the Energy's amazing  Miranda first shared the two were  engaged after a year of dating on  Instagram in July 2016 posting this  gorgeous shot of her ring with a custom  snapchat filter overlay of course she  captioned the pic  I said yes it's great this will be Evans  first marriage and Miranda second she  and actor Orlando Bloom were married  from 2010 to 2013 and share a son  six-year-old Flynn Christopher bloom  it's remarkable to see congratulations  to the newlyweds  [Music]  you